Keith's Allison's personal radicalism
fits into another really troubling trend
on the left that has massive
implications for the country and for you
last time we talked to journalists
Chadwick more about how on the left in
the name of fighting racism it is now
common to attack people on the basis of
their race if you want to see racism
everywhere if you're brainwashed to see
racism everywhere or homophobia
everywhere or whatever then you will
that's the world you were living you
know I was having a conversation with
with the woman not too long ago about
this a young upper-middle class black
woman and she was talking about how
badly she you know gets treated on the
street here in New York and I said to
her what if you lived for one day as a
white woman and you were treated the
exact same way money Presley is a lawyer
and a democratic commentator and she
joins us Tammany great to see you good
to see you totally opposed to I think
I'm 48 I grew up in a country where it
you had to be and most people I knew
were totally opposed to attacking other
people on the basis of the race because
you can't control your race right you're
not responsible for it you're saying you
grew up in a country where like that's
where I grew up that that everyone said
that at school most people I knew said
they believed that maybe they didn't but
you kind of had to say that and I
believe did I still believe it now I
live in a world where the left still
says that and yet they do it and somehow
exempt themselves from the normal rules
so you're racist but when I attacked you
in the basis of your race I'm not racist
I'm virtuous how does that work that
seems insane to me I don't know how we
end up in this kind of warped world
where I end up doing the history lesson
of history I know you know but when
you're saying you grew up in a world
where people knew it was wrong to attack
others on the basis of race I'm
wondering if you were in the United
States of America I was country and you
should believe that and that's a good
belief but if you grew up in the United
States of America then you know that not
just people's belief systems but
codified laws right discriminated
against people expressly because of
their race that's
are you aware of that okay 48 I'm not 78
that didn't exist where I grew up I'm
just telling you this just true but the
point is I believed it I still believe
it why don't you believe it we're just a
year apart and if you're saying because
you're 48 not 78 are you saying that
segregation which really didn't formally
end until we were already gets rolled to
attack people on the base of the race
that's all I'm saying do it and so for
people of color have been attacked
because of their race not for decades
but for generation agree then it's it's
really reasonable to expect that they
would take issue with that and with
those who have done it for generations
and I can't attack their race missing
there should never be physical attacks
of any but and there shouldn't be
emotional or verbal about how about just
crap how about just criticizing people
on the basis of their race you can't
control this out a choice that you made
you shouldn't ever hold someone's race
against him cuz it's not his fault
that's the whole point that's why racism
is wrong right that is exactly why
racism exactly why is it doing that so
and I don't know you know when you say
the left
I wonder who those people don't know
every time I pull a BuzzFeed or
Huffington Post or any lefty site
there's some piece about white people or
a scourge on America they're bad it's
like I'm not defending white people all
I'm saying is you shouldn't write off
any group of people on the basis of
their race I thought that was the
definition of racism and now it's very
common and I frankly haven't read any
articles that say white people are this
or white people or that it's just on the
basis of their race if you are white and
you are also a bigot if you are white
and you were also a racist then I've
read many things that discuss a lack of
understanding in this country I haven't
heard anybody say in the last 10 years
too many white guys there's just a white
guy thing you haven't seen any Pete no
I'm serious too many white guys where
Tucker anywhere you haven't seen anyone
really so my question is
and that really wouldn't make sense for
the past ten years since the numbers of
white males are decreasing in our
country and the numbers of Latinos
African Americans etc are increased so I
guess I have heard people talking about
that balance and how that can be scary
for those who are using being in power
don't patronize me
I'm merely making something that can we
agree that it's always wrong always no
matter who's doing it to whom to dismiss
people attack them judge them on the
basis of immutable characteristics
racial characteristics that they can't
control period yes Amen absolutely and
those racial characteristics really are
just skin remember race is a construct
it's a legal and social content why
United States that's kind of the nation
making the origin are different why
would you ever give preference in hiring
or college admissions to someone solely
on the basis of something he couldn't
control is that the definition of racism
because of what we just finished talking
about you just agreed it was so it's why
I thought it was wrong to attack on the
basis of race I didn't say it was wrong
to help on the base you've got let's say
you have one job and two people and you
make the decision the deciding factor is
the race of one of the people one person
is being hurt because he's the wrong
race why would why is that okay because
he's gotten 350 maybe 400 years of
benefit he has right do you know him are
you just you know all you know about him
is his race any of they're saying that
he's benefit exactly and but you don't
know anything about him other than his
race so you're saying that all people of
a certain color have something in common
which is kind of the definition of
racism is now that's also the definition
of discrimination because all
african-american people in the United
States have something in common it's
that they were discriminated
if you know any these are the five days
I they have something in common in that
they were selection Belgium yesterday he
could have there's no can I write to it
but you think it's okay to deny him
something because of his color I think
that the system itself in order to fix
what is the one original centre between
racism I don't consider that racism it's
not racism when you're doing a state
racist if I'm in power as an African
American woman and I insist upon you
walking around with one hand tied behind
your back but I want you to plow a field
then the guy from Belgium who didn't do
anything
who's not connected in any way can we go
to use my analogy at the finish at first
an individual suffers yes you don't
consider that racism because why no it's
not because the numbers of people in
this country who have been
disproportionately discriminated against
for hundreds of years are such that
there has to be a correction for it so
some people have to just suffer action
basis of country those people have been
African Americans and other people the
guy who must suffer because other people
who look like him did something weak
because I yes well I'm in charge now
right that sounds like collective
punishment well you're probably an
innocent party to Tucker but here you
are with this show and there probably
are a number of similarly situated
talented african-american males who
could do just as good a job or better
than you you may be getting the benefit
of your race do you think so because if
that's the only different thing between
you I think than another the Charlie
jumplist I don't think that you should
punish people for things they didn't do
I agree things they're not responsible
for you I just argued that you should
you should you don't worry dude that you
should not punishment it's not
punishment okay it's not aliens meant
we're out of time it's not happy new
year Tucker not getting jobs good to see
you thank you to see you too